sorry Muslims but you can't have Jesus
well you can have Jesus but you need to
leave Islam for that I'll tell you about
it later in the meantime I dare you to
refute what you're about to hear in this
video any 50 of you any thousand of you
take the shot and prove me wrong you see
Jesus just doesn't fit into your
religion trying to make Jesus fit into
Islam is like trying to make science or
logic or basic ethics fit into Islam you
can pretend but not a good fit can this
mug hold a star can a garbage can
contain the
sun I should point out however that
there's a part of me that really likes
the fact that you really really want
Jesus on your side everyone wants Jesus
on their side which is a pretty big
compliment to Jesus after all besides
you who wants Muhammad on their side
child marriage
Advocates so on behalf of Christians
everywhere I thank you for adding your
voice to the global chorus of
non-christians who Praise Jesus we'd be
happy to return the favor but we can't
because Muhammad now for you non-muslims
who are watching since you clicked on
this video it's safe to say that you
have an internet connection and if you
have an internet connection you've
probably heard that Jesus was a Muslim
and as world-renowned historical Jesus
scholar sneo said Jesus Christ was a
Muslim and sn's expert testimony is
echoed by A Chorus of daag gists who
declare Jesus was a Muslim peace be upon
Him Jesus was Muslim I am way closer to
the teachings of prophet Jesus as a
Muslim than I ever was as a Christian
Jesus is a Muslim Jesus was Muslim and
worshiped Allah not himself and who can
forget the Muslim Cowboy Jesus is a
Muslim not a Jew God
y but what evidence do our Muslim
friends have that Jesus was a
Muslim exactly there is none so if
there's absolutely no evidence that
Jesus was a Muslim and if all of the
evidence we have tells us that he most
certainly was not a Muslim why are
Muslims obsessed with claiming that
Jesus was a
Muslim because Muhammad said that Jesus
was a Muslim of course Muhammad also
said that duel carain AKA Alexander the
Great was a devout Muslim who traveled
so far west he found the place where the
sun sets and that the sun sets in a
muddy pool Muhammad said that stars are
missiles that Allah uses to shoot demons
he said that semen forms between the
backbone and the ribs he said that
nothing can make water impure he said
that Adam was 90 ft tall he said that
Jews call Ezra the Son of God he said
that Mary the mother of Jesus and Miriam
the sister of Aaron and Moses were the
same person even though they lived many
centuries apart he said that Satan
urinates in people's ears and hangs out
in people's noses and passes wind to
keep from hearing the call to
prayer why would we believe anything
Muhammad said unless he happens to be
giving a tutorial on how to manipulate
people into believing anything you say
no matter how insane it is because he
would be an expert on that Muhammad is
the least reliable source of information
in history on History why because he was
a caravan robber and I'm not criticizing
him for being a Caravan robber I'm
drawing attention to the fact that he
had the mind of a caravan robber someone
who sees something he likes and takes it
even if it doesn't belong to
him that's what Muhammad did in life and
it's what he did in
religion those camels are hauling dates
I like dates so I'll just take them and
they'll be mine Christianity has Jesus I
like Jesus so so I'll just take him and
make him part of my
religion and once Muhammad decides to
rob a religion his followers join the
robbery by twisting scripture and
committing fallacy after fallacy here's
Eddie from the dean show imitating his
Prophet by robbing
Christianity Jesus fasted like Muslims
do for Ramadan Jesus was a
Muslim Jesus fasted like Muslims do for
r radan how do Muslims fast for Ramadan
they Gorge themselves with food twice
per day and call it fasting now I'm not
here to judge another culture but what
Muslims call fasting is what the rest of
the world calls feasting Jesus didn't
Feast for 40 days he fasted for 40 days
Jesus did not fast like Muslims fast for
Ramadan and Jesus told his followers not
to fast in order to be seen by others he
told his followers to fast in secret do
Muslims fast in secret no they make a
big show out of it and announce to the
world that they're fasting even though
they're
feasting Jesus condemned Islamic fasting
how can dagand ists claim with a
straight face that Jesus was fasting
like Muslims fast because they see what
they want to see and all they want to
see is whatever Muhammad told them to
see here's another from our good friend
Eddie Jesus prayed the same way Muslims
pray to God because Jesus was a Muslim
submitting his will to god wow Jesus
didn't just fast the same way Muslims
fast he also prayed the same way Muslims
pray in John 17:1 Jesus lifted up his
eyes to heaven and said father the hour
has come glorify your son that the son
may glorify you is this how Muslims pray
lifting up their eyes to Heaven speaking
to their father in
Heaven no but again Muhammad's followers
see what they want to see and all they
want to see is whatever Muhammad told
them to see so they don't go to John 171
they go to Matthew
26:39 as Eddie says in his little
graphic Jesus worshiped Allah this way
Matthew
26:39 and here's how Muslims are
encouraged to read Matthew
2639 and going a little farther he fell
on his face and prayed there you see he
fell on his face and prayed that's how
Muslims pray I guess Jesus must have
been a Muslim after all oh wait maybe we
should at least finish the verse and
going a little far he fell on his face
and prayed saying my father if it be
possible let this cup pass from me
nevertheless not as I will but as you
will my
father is Jesus the son of Allah is
Allah the
father I wonder what the Quran says
about calling Allah father oh here it is
Surah 19: 88 to
93 and they say the beneficent hath
taken unto himself a son assuredly ye
utter a disastrous thing whereby almost
the heavens are torn and the Earth is
split asunder and the mountains fall in
Ruins that ye ascribe unto the
beneficent a son when it is not meat for
the Majesty of the beneficent that he
should choose a son there is none in the
heavens and the Earth but cometh unto
the beneficent as a
slave when people say that has a son or
that Allah is a father the universe
almost falls
apart why because it's the sin of shik
associating a partner with Allah shik is
the worst possible sin in Islam Sur four
verse
48 Lo Allah forgiveth not that a partner
should be ascribed unto him he forgiveth
all save that to whom he will who so
ascribe part ERS to Allah he hath indeed
invented a tremendous
sin Allah can forgive anything else but
he can't forgive associating a partner
with him he can't forgive calling
someone the Son of God now since Muslims
believe in a Doctrine called ismat
Alania Allah's protection of the
prophets from falling into major error
Jesus obviously couldn't have committed
the worst possible sin if he was a
Muslim
right and those who were around Jesus
wouldn't have gotten the impression that
he was the son of God because he
wouldn't have given them that impression
right and there's no way that God and
angels and Prophets would identify Jesus
as the Son of God right so we know what
we're definitely not going to find if
Jesus was a Muslim Prophet we're not
going to find tons and tons of Sherk
from Jesus and from those around him
let's see if our expectations are
confirmed by the
evidence Jesus was baptized by John the
Baptist and in Matthew 3 when Jesus
comes out of the water the spirit of God
descends as a dove and a voice out of
the heavens proclaims this is my beloved
Son with whom I am well pleased a voice
out of the heavens says this is my
beloved Son this was the voice of of the
father but how do we know that the
father was referring to Jesus how do we
know he wasn't talking about John the
Baptist or someone else well the Holy
Spirit descended from heaven and landed
on Jesus notice the father and the Holy
Spirit together identify Jesus as the
Son of God and Jesus repeatedly
identifies himself as the Son of God at
his trial for instance in Mark 14 the
high priest asks him are you the Christ
the son of the Blessed if Muslims are
right this would be a really good time
for Jesus to say what you're crazy son
of the Blessed whatever gave you that
idea I'm just the prophet of Islam
instead Jesus answers I am and you will
see the son of man seated at the right
hand of power and coming with the Clouds
Of Heaven this is where our Muslim
friends missed the part about Jesus
Calling himself the Son of God and they
say but look he called himself the son
of man you see he was just a man and
this is where it helps to have some clue
what you're talking about Jesus called
himself the son of man coming with the
Clouds Of Heaven he was claiming to be
the mysterious son of man prophesied in
the book of The Prophet Daniel 7:
13-4 where Daniel says in my vision at
at night I looked and there before me
was one like a son of man coming with
the Clouds Of Heaven he approached the
Ancient of Days and was led into his
presence he was given Authority glory
and Sovereign power All Nations and
peoples of every language worshiped him
his Dominion is an everlasting Dominion
that will not pass away and his kingdom
is one that will never be
destroyed the son of man coming with the
clouds of Heaven is the Divine Son of
God so Father Son and Holy Spirit are in
total agreement that Jesus is the son of
God in Luke 1 the angel Gabriel says to
Mary do not be afraid Mary for you have
found favor with God and behold you will
conceive in your womb and bear a son and
you shall call his name Jesus he will be
great and will be called the son of the
most high Jesus is to be called the son
of the most high according to the angel
Gabriel what about the prophets John the
Baptist was a prophet according to both
Christianity and Islam in John 1 he
tells his followers about Jesus and says
I have seen and have borne witness that
this is the Son of God that's the
testimony of the prophets how about
Jesus Apostles in Matthew 14 Jesus walks
on water during a storm after stepping
into the boat the wind stops and his
disciples Bow Down and Worship Him
saying truly you are the Son of God in
Matthew 16 Jesus asks his disciples who
do you say that I am Peter answers you
are the Christ the son of the Living God
now if Jesus was just a prophet and his
disciples who were Muslims according to
the Quran were completely
misunderstanding who he was this would
have been the perfect time to rebuke
Peter and to say no Peter I'm just a
prophet of Islam instead Jesus says to
him blessed are you Simon bar Jonah for
flesh and blood has not revealed this to
you but my father who is in
heaven that's strange Jesus says that
the Father revealed that he's the son of
God why wouldn't the father reveal that
Jesus was a merely human prophet of
Islam and why does Jesus even call him
my father when that's the unforgivable
sin of Sherk in Islam but it's not just
his male followers who call him the Son
of God in John 11 Lazarus dies and
Martha the sister of Lazarus meets Jesus
on his way to raise Lazarus from the
dead we read Jesus said to her your
brother will rise again Martha said to
him I know that he will rise again in
the resurrection Resurrection on the
last day Jesus said to her I am the
resurrection and the life whoever
believes in me though he die yet shall
he live and everyone who lives and
Believes In Me shall never die do you
believe this she said to him yes Lord I
believe that you are the Christ the son
of God who is coming into the world
Martha and the apostles and John the
Baptist were all Jews who believed in
Jesus but even the Jewish leaders who
rejected Jesus admitted that he was
claiming to be the Son of God at his
crucifixion they mocked him and said he
saved others he cannot save himself he
is the king of Israel let him come down
now from the cross and we will believe
in him he trusts in God let God deliver
him now if he desires him for he said I
am the Son of God so whether they
believed him or didn't believe him the
Jews of his time acknowledged that Jesus
was claiming to be the Son of God and
even some of the Romans called Jesus the
son of God when Jesus died by
crucifixion there was an earthquake and
the Roman Centurion and those who were
with him shouted truly this was the son
of God even demons would call Jesus the
son of God as he was casting them out of
people we read in Luke 4 and demons also
came out of many crying you are the Son
of
God now think about the witnesses we
have the father identifies Jesus as the
Son of God Jesus identifies himself as
the Son of God the Holy Spirit
identifies Jesus as the Son of God the
angel Gabriel identifies Jesus as the
Son of God the prophet John the Baptist
identifies Jesus as the Son of God Jesus
Apostles identify him as the son of God
Martha identifies him as the Son of God
Roman soldiers identify him as the Son
of God demons identify him as the Son of
God and people who certainly didn't
believe that he's the son of God
publicly proclaimed that he was claiming
to be the Son of
God seems like a pretty good lineup of
witnesses so what's the
problem well about six centuries after
everyone who could possibly identify
Jesus as the son of God identified him
as the Son of God an illiterate Arabian
Caravan robber named Muhammad a man who
married a six-year-old girl a man who
married the divorced wife of his own
adopted son after causing the divorce by
lusting after her a man who bought owned
sold and traded black African slaves a
man whose first impression of his
Revelations was that they were demonic a
man who believed he was a victim of
black magic a man who repeatedly tried
to hurl himself off a cliff this guy
comes along and tells his followers that
Jesus isn't the Son of God and never
claimed to be and his followers believe
him they believe the least reliable
person in the history of humanity the
most obvious false prophet ever instead
of believing the unparalleled cloud of
witnesses who affirmed that Jesus is the
son of God and since they believe
Muhammad and not the unparalleled cloud
of witnesses who affirm ired that Jesus
is the son of God they're forced to
cherry-pick and to lie and to completely
distort and misrepresent what Jesus says
in the
Bible what does Jesus actually say in
the verse Muslims point to when they
want to show that Jesus prayed like a
Muslim my
father what did he say in John
17:1 father the hour has come glorify
your son that the son may glorify
you did Jesus pray like a Muslim no
according to the Quran the way Jesus
prayed in the gospels would be the
unforgivable sin of Sher Jesus would be
a mushrik how do Muslims look at a
passage where Jesus according to Islam
is committing the worst possible sin and
somehow see proof that Jesus is a devout
Muslim they see what they want to see
and all they want to see is confirmation
of anything Muhammad said so they're not
really going to the life of Jesus and
finding out that Jesus was a Muslim
they've already decided that Jesus was a
Muslim and they go to the Bible with
their minds already made up and
cherry-pick verses and twist them to get
them to line up with
Islam and the number of fallacies they
commit along the way is truly
mindboggling when your Muslim friends
try to convince you that Jesus was a
Muslim they're going to give you a
strange mixture of cherry-picking
equivocation the emical fallacy the m
and Bailey fallacy and the fallacy of
the undistributed middle just to name a
few cherry-picking is going to the
evidence and only selecting the evidence
you can use to support your claim while
ignoring all the evidence that refutes
your claim Muslims will go to the
gospels where father son Holy Spirit the
angel Gabriel John the Baptist and so on
all identify Jesus as the Son of God
Muslims will ignore all of this and fix
it on something like Matthew
2639 and they'll even cherry-pick the
part of the verse that they can use they
literally can't finish the verse they're
twisting because simply finishing the
verse would refute them equivocation is
using a word that has multiple meanings
and switching the meanings in the course
of your argument Muslims will will say
Jesus was a Muslim but when you
challenge them by showing that Jesus
condemned some of the core teachings of
Islam and repeatedly committed what
would be the worst possible sin in Islam
they'll say hey man a Muslim is just
someone who submits to God Jesus
submitted his will to God so he's a
Muslim so he's a Muslim even though he
condemned some of the core teachings of
Islam and committed the worst possible
sin in
Islam what are they doing here they're
switching between different meanings of
the word Muslim we could also call this
the edical fallacy which is a specific
form of equivocation you commit the
eological fallacy when you're using a
word that people understand because the
word is commonly used but then when
challenged you revert to some original
or earlier meaning of the word so for
instance the word Hindu originally
referred to the people who lived beyond
the indis river and was then used to
refer to people from India much later it
was applied to people with certain
religious beliefs if we wanted to be
like the daag guys we could say that
zacher Nik is a Hindu and when Muslims
challenge us and say why are you calling
zachar Nike a Hindu he's not a Hindu but
a Muslim we can reply but the word Hindu
used to mean someone from India and
zachar is from India so he's a
Hindu this would be pretty silly but
it's exactly what Muslims do when they
say Jesus was a Muslim we can show them
that Jesus can't possibly be a Muslim in
the normal sense of the word Muslim
where Muslim means a follower of Islam
so they reply ah but the word Muslim
technically means someone who submits to
God Jesus submitted to God therefore
Jesus was a
Muslim it's easy to expose them when
they do this you can just say oh great
so the Apostle Paul was a Muslim because
he submitted to God Christians and Jews
are Muslims because we submit to God the
pope is a Muslim because he submits to
God suddenly your Muslim friends will
start insisting that to be a Muslim you
have to submit to God in the Islamic way
but that destroys their claim that Jesus
was a Muslim because Jesus did not
submit to God in the Islamic way he
submitted to the father as the Incarnate
son we could also say that they're
committing the m and Bailey fallacy here
the mot is some sort of stronghold or
Fortress like a tower the Bailey is the
surrounding area which is more difficult
to defend you commit the mot and Bailey
fallacy when you make a controversial
claim but then as soon as you're
challenged you Retreat to a less
controversial easier to defend claim
suppose someone says biological males
who identify as females should be
allowed to compete against biological
females in women's sports that's a
controversial claim suppose you
challenge the claim and the person says
hey I'm just saying that all human
beings have
rights that's a less controversial
position there's a fallacy here because
the person is pretending that he's
defended the controversial claim the
Bailey when he simply retreated to an
uncontroversial claim the M what do
Muslims say Jesus was a Muslim that's
controversial it's claiming that Jesus
was an adherent of the same religion as
Muhammad but when you challenge them on
this controversial claim they Retreat to
we're just saying that Jesus submitted
to God M and Bailey
fallacy but we can't leave out the
fallacy of the undistributed middle to
explain why it's called the fallacy of
the undistributed middle I'd have to go
through the rules of the syllogism and
the requirements for Distributing What's
called the middle term I'll save that
for a different video it's easier to
spot the fallacy by using examples the
fallacy of the undistributed middle
usually goes something like all A's are
c b is C therefore B is a this may look
confusing it's not all C cats are
mammals my dog is a mammal therefore my
dog is a cat pretty stupid right Elvis
liked peanut butter and banana
sandwiches I like peanut butter and
banana sandwiches therefore I'm Elvis
really really bad you can instantly get
Muslims to see the problem by arguing
the pagans took a pilgrimage to Mecca
Muhammad took a pilgrimage to Mecca
therefore Muhammad was a p
for some reason if you presented this
argument to a Muslim he would instantly
see that there's a problem he might not
know what the fallacy is or why it's a
fallacy but he would see that there's a
problem and yet when a daaga uses the
exact same fallacy to argue Muslims pray
Jesus prayed therefore Jesus was a
Muslim or Muslims fast Jesus fasted
their for Jesus was a Muslim suddenly
they think the reasoning is airtight and
irrefutable if you were to use this
fallacy against Muhammad your Muslim
friends would use their god-given
critical thinking ability to spot the
fallacy but when a daag gist uses the
exact same fallacy to support something
Muhammad said your Muslim friends turn
off their god-given critical thinking
ability so they can continue believing
Muhammad putting all of this together on
one side we have an unparalleled cloud
of witnesses affirming that Jesus was
most certainly not a Muslim because he's
the son of God and he can't be a Muslim
if he's the son of God on the other side
we have an unparalleled cloud of
fallacies my Muslim friends if Defending
Your Prophet forces you to cherry-pick
forces you to twist scripture forces you
to commit an endless array of fallacies
forces you to turn off your critical
thinking ability you need a different
Prophet the truth doesn't need
cherry-picking the truth doesn't need
Scripture twisting the truth doesn't
need fallacious
reasoning if you want Jesus on your side
you can have Jesus on your side but not
by lying about him and twisting his
words
if you want Jesus on your side you have
to reject Muhammad the most obvious
false prophet in history and believe
that Jesus is the Divine Son of God who
died on the cross for sins and rose from
the dead there's no way to reconcile the
Jesus of the Quran with the Jesus of the
Bible you think you can fix your problem
by saying oh but the Bible's been
corrupted we still use it when it's
convenient but when the Bible refutes us
will just say it's been
corrupted fortunately for you and your
salvation your God and your Prophet
blocked that escape when they affirmed
the inspiration the preservation and the
authority of the Jewish and Christian
scriptures if you'd like to see how your
God and your Prophet block your escape
and how the truth leads you out of Islam
be sure to check out my videos
99.8% of muslims don't know says this
about the Bible and what the Quran
really says about the
gospel and when the truth sets you
free let me know in the comments section
[Music]